Star Wars is getting so scary now in
their shows this is scary this is this
is too scary
too too spooky too spooky
what is this
[Laughter]
yeah I mean I think we all knew this
right Gideon he's out there somewhere
yeah but this is is he just Leia space
flighting married
what if she's still there just pointing
like Superman
[Music]
does this also remind you of Jaws a
little bit where he's like go through
the sunken and then the head comes in
yeah
by
mandalorians
that's a big jump frame job frame job
that's a frame job just a little chunk
of best car welcome back to New
rockstars the Mandalorian chapter 21
brought pirate king gorion chart back
from Revenge on Navarro I know I said
shart not Shard but you know what this
is a shirt of a human being if you ask
me uh the only thing standing in his way
were a few Scrappy mandalorians and well
you know that's it but we got a lot of
other questions coming out of this
episode like who's that was that zap and
then we also have uh a big frame job
going on at the end who really is trying
to frame the mandalorians these are
questions we will ask today as we begin
with our ceremonial swear of dank Fair
dank Barrick gorion shark this is break
room presents Wikileaks our weekly
Mandalorian after show I'm Eric Voss my
Easter egg breakdown of this episode is
coming tomorrow but right now I'm here
discussing this episode with Tommy
bechtold and Hector Navarro yes what's
up boys oh my God this episode so
jam-packed with things going on let's
talk about what happened what the fat
happened to this episode well grief car
guy and his Engineers who just refers to
as Engineers all right we don't want to
give them too many names so we got to
pay him our continuing Navarro's glow up
when gory and Shard returns with his
pirate Corsair we may remember Shard
from the season premiere he kind of
looks like a seaweed salad grief sends a
distress signal and it's heard by Carson
tiva in a new Republic Pilot bar real
Top Gun Vibes here straight down to the
billiard type game they are playing yeah
how often do you think Carson tiva gets
86 he's playing the piano the space
piano Max Revo comes in that's my job
I played piano with my meaty thighs uh
because uh look up Max repo legs if you
haven't that's one of my favorite things
to do stop making us do that every time
you bring it back cerevo time look up
his legs look up his legs all right we
get a cameo from Zeb why I don't know
who tells Teva the Republic isn't
answering dispatches tiva decides he's
gonna handle business in person which
means he's headed to Coruscant where he
meets with Tim Meadows playing Colonel
Tuttle we can't just make a phone call
he has to go in person or you're not
answering the message
by the way I loved it like they work so
hard on the costuming of aliens and make
them so practical looking on this show
and Zeb is just like drawn it they're
just like he's completely computer
animated Oh I thought Zep looked pretty
good no that's me they got the same guy
Bloom to come back to voice him I mean
if we see Zeb you know Harris and Doula
can't be too far away right yeah this is
exciting yeah I mean Tommy Tommy you
were like why did we see Zeb you know
why we saw Zeb they're setting up the
Ahsoka show I also thought he looked
pretty sweet but it's you know it's all
Star Wars dude there's animated
characters there's puppetry you got you
got the CG looking very fluid Zed but
then you also have the pirate puppet
the whole time it's just my lips barely
match and it's the best it's the best
yeah he didn't look as good as CAD Bane
CAD Bane I think was the gold standard
of like adapted an animated character to
practical live action you may say
computer animation and puppets but it's
still real to me damn it
I guess uh Hector I think this goes back
to the point I think you made last week
that in this vast Galaxy of Star Wars
everything is very small because of
course Kiva runs into Zeb at the Pilot
bar anyway back to Coruscant tunnel
informs TiVo that they're a little
swamped right now with requests and
since Navarro didn't join the Federation
they can't prioritize its protection
Elia Kane is eavesdropping and she says
this might be a teacher moment tivus you
know he looks at her and goes that's a
really Imperial way of thinking and
she's like don't worry tunnel goes to
Defender and she's like oh people make
fun of me all the time Winks at him bats
her eyes and he's like wow This Woman's
really something special don't you think
it's weird that like he would so rush to
defend a former Nazi like he likes they
are going to to protect these people and
give them third chances fourth chances
fifth chances it's like allow them to be
bullied a little bit I agree I think
it's planting seeds of uh her having him
wrapped around her finger in terms of
their boss subordinate relationship and
probably eventually using that to obtain
access to things that someone in me sure
rehabilitation program may not get I
also just want to point out how um you
know swamped supposedly the new
Republicans with red tape yet they have
this open door policy where any Coast
Guard pilot can just walk into the
Pentagon and give requests in person
like if you can't get us on the phone
just show up at this any time you know
you can just kind of walk right in until
you suck your pilot helmet in over in
the cubby hole and then we'll take your
concerns directly I don't want to be
some somebody who defends any formal
Imperial because Star Wars generally
speaking Imperials are bad we know what
they're a metaphor for but I think it's
so interesting that Carson Teva is a
character immediately jumps to like
disliking this woman when she walks into
this office and starts just by clocking
her badge yeah I'm the former Imperial
whereas the Tim Meadows character his
perspective is just hey she's trying to
make a living here like she's just
trying to contribute to the thing but if
we didn't know
that this woman was maybe not to be
trusted if we didn't see the things that
MAF Gideon did would we feel the same
way about Carson Teva like jumping up
her ass in that moment we might also be
like whoa Carson like you got to give a
person a second chance here but we just
happen to know that like she's doing
stuff and this seems very very
suspicious even to the point where he
Tim Meadows tunnel Colonel Tuttle even
goes well you spent a little time in the
outer rim didn't you do it like it's
like yeah working for a warlord like yes
he spent some time in the outer rim what
are you talking about uh can you imagine
being in Argentina in like 1955 and
seeing a German person be like well you
spent some time in Germany it's like no
they were there doing bad things like
you've got a little sister in Poland in
the 40s yeah yeah uh if you're here in
Argentina and you were yeah exactly
anyway we then see cargo and the
surviving citizens of Navarro have taken
Refuge outside a badly damaged City
cargo get a great the classic Star Wars
view the the the the binoculars he looks
over size things aren't looking good for
Navarro tiva communicates with r5d4 God
what a great moment and locates the
covert I served with one with someone
amongst your ranks r5d4 just kind of
goes yes I've been physically
traumatized this entire season I screwed
you guys over and told him where you
were I don't blame him
that's what you get when you send this
Droid to be your probe to wander into
the possibly toxic even though toxic air
wouldn't hurt a Droid he's just scared
he's just he's just scared also they
literally don't buckle him into uh
bocatan ship and she like jumps the
light speed and he flies backwards so
he's been banged around loose in the
back seat there that's right yeah you
can't leave your droids loose never
leave just a couple like two liters of
uh Publix brand Cola just rolling around
in the back seat of the car you got to
be careful you gotta lock that [__] down
right come on
all right so tiva communicates like we
said with the Droid begging the
mandalorians to help Navarro din takes
Steven's case pleads it to the rest of
the covert explaining that they can set
up a new Homeland on the land grief
offered him in the season premiere it
looks like dangerous gonna be denied
before he gets some unlikely support
from possibisla who's like you saved my
son I'll save your uh city which is a
good tip for Tat it's pretty great he
made that speech we didn't know which
way he was going to go it's kind of like
that Keegan Michael Key sketch where
he's playing like the judge on a on a
cooking show and he's like
a delicious meal a delicious for someone
with no sense of taste just kind of
going any try is what I would say if I
didn't feel the opposite yes all right
so it's on it's gonna be dead it's gonna
be Bo's gonna drop uh the mandalorians
Donna Navarro the covert flies and
engages the Pirates there's some great
land and air battle scenes Dan basically
wipes out the Pirates entire like
auxiliary Fleet well Bo drops the rest
of the covert off in Midtown Navarro to
kick ass when we finally get to see the
armor in battle it didn't disappoint
what did you guys think when she was
swinging that hammer around I thought it
was great I like that they are I like
that the hammer went from like a conch
shell speaking tool in the meeting to a
straight up weapon of Destruction and
not only did she use the hammer she got
the she got the tongue yeah the tongs
down there that was impressive pull in
the back of somebody's neck like oh
thank you you got my pinched nerve oh
also that hurts a lot no that whole
thing that whole thing was so rad and uh
so exciting to see yeah that Talking
Stick go from from like a camp item like
a campfire Talking Stick item to that
kind of a weapon and um I really love
the armor I I want to talk about what
happened at the end of this episode but
I'll save it until Tommy gets us there
but I I I enjoyed the action uh for this
entire sequence so so so so much just
like cool action figure stuff it was
great also what I think was is a uh you
correct me if I'm wrong a modulated
Wilhelm scream from the Gunner as she
threw him off the thing it was like that
was definitely something yeah yeah it
sounded like that uh I enjoyed it anyway
uh finally Bo and didn't take out all of
gorion shards and James and he crashes
in a place of Glory making some kelp
chips you know what I'm saying dog you
put those in the oven at 450 they're
delicious little sea salt on gorion
Shard he's gonna make a great meal did
you guys think that when his ship
crashed into the volcano it was going to
like rupture the volcano kind of like a
Lord of the Rings the rings of power
kind of something like oh yeah oh it's
an active volcano there's lava flows
Like You Do Not Crash that big of a ship
into the site of a volcano I thought it
was going to just destroy the entire
town with lava that would have been
ironic if they were like we're saved and
now we're all burnt alive
Hey listen Navarro Navarro is not a city
it's a people all right if Thor Ragnarok
taught us anything it's at the people of
Navarro all 24 of them could have easily
relocated to somewhere else they would
have been fine it's fine it's fine yeah
hey I do like there's 24 of it it was
just like a handful of them because they
don't want to get all these extras in
there yeah but it's like everybody's
hiding in there yeah yeah no kids
thousands of us died all of our kids are
dead but you know what guys I'm gonna
get us through this the Pirates killed
all the children in that school because
they wanted their bar back uh which was
the whole impetus for this grief gives a
motivational speech and says all of the
land from the Western lava Flats to
Bullock Canyon will belong to the
mandalorians it's got to be a reference
to actor Jeremy Bullock who was the
physical actor that depicted Boba Fett I
thought that was a great sort of tribute
to him and being a part of the Boba Fett
slash Mandalorian Legacy and history of
Star Wars that was great that was really
cool I love that the armor requests a
one-on-one with Bo and tells her that
since she saw the mythosaur she is the
one to unite all mandalorians in a new
age they take a walk outside and Bo
removes her helmet under the armorer's
orders and the armor pronounces her one
to lead a United Mandalorian front while
everyone else is like why did she take
her helmet off I thought she just put it
back on finally diva is out on patrol
when he discovers a destroyed Lambda
ship it's confirmed to be Gideon's
transport ship and there's a fragment of
beskar alloy seemingly framing the
mandalorians for breaking muff Gideon
out of jail you're right that's a frame
job that's a frame there's no way any
Mandalorian that we have gotten to know
in this show three seasons in is any way
involved in that job right there there's
in that extraction it has to be a frame
job it has to be moth Gideon playing the
long game I'll maybe even give you that
maybe Admiral thrawn might have
something to do with it because he's
somebody who is who is an expert at
crafting sort of like game plans to be
able to to take down an enemy speaking
of frame jobs you're going to want to
frame one of these shirts that we're
selling over with our merch Partners at
nerd riot.shop we have some great new
Mandalorian inspired items in their new
the way collection including this
foundling shirt and another shirt called
The Bounty Hunter with designs inspired
by the best garstiel of Mandalore and if
you purchase one of these shirts you can
opt to unlock a shout out on this show
like this one from pretty R thank you
for the breakdowns Eric thank you Tommy
for always making us laugh new rock
stars is awesome screw you Hector just
kidding I'm sure she just didn't know
you were going to be on this week or she
would have she would have shouted you
out too so visit nerd riot.shop now to
grab one of these great designs and
don't take it off until to the finale
next month it's okay Tommy I'm used to
that on the internet that also could
have been me too somebody who does know
that I was on the episode guys I want to
get to the questions now to discuss this
episode for certainly raised several
questions but there are a few that I
think uh Rose to the top of this for me
first of all are the mandalorians being
set up and who the fet took moff Gideon
yeah I think Hector brought up some uh
really good points with this possibility
that it is thrawn just because if you
step back and look at the big picture we
know that thrawn is a villain that they
want to set up on this show and if you
know they are saying next episode Bryce
Dallas Howard directed it to certain
it's like 44 minutes long A lot of
people are saying that this is going to
be a huge huge episode and I think like
bringing in ahsoka's Hunt for thrawn
here setting up the Ahsoka show later
this year hopefully later this year I
think is the the overall game plan right
now I do have some questions about
logically why he set it up this way in
particular and what his issue is with
the mandalorians I mean if if it was a
setup like Carson tiva bought that Hook
Line and Sinker oh there's a chunk of
bed scar well it must mean it's a
Mandalorian job don't you think the
mandalorians wouldn't leave any scrap of
bescar behind like their whole thing is
reclaiming every bit of best guard they
would not leave a chunk of bescar in a
crime scene they're pretty clean in
their in their jobs also if it was moth
Gideon why would they extract them don't
you think they would just blow up the
entire ship or they'd take them and
they'd leave his body there they
wouldn't kill some new Republic officers
too like they they aren't like starting
fights that way they're kind of hanging
out in the shadows unless there's
another branch of mandalorians there's
some people at Concord Dawn or something
like that uh there's some uh cousins of
Mr Fett who are still hanging out uh but
I I just think that this is someone who
has an ax to grind it is whoever
attacked bocaton's compound I think on
kalavala and I speculated before that
that was thrawn it's the fact like we
still have a lot of questions about why
thrawn would be you know so pissed off
the mandalorians I think he views the
mandalorians as a threat to whatever
he's trying to accomplish and he's
trying to create a wedge and he looks at
like what's the most powerful cult out
there right now who it can help chip
away at the new Republic uh the
mandalorians and maybe and that that
could just be like the case yeah I think
it could also be Eric again such
excellent points such excellent points
but I think it could also be something
where thrawn working with moth Gideon
maybe he's been working with Gideon this
entire time also is just gunning for
this baby Yoda this grogu is so
significantly important to them for
their Palpatine first order final order
clone plans that it's just about thrawn
and Gideon manipulating whatever
whatever they can manipulate to get back
to din jar and to get back to that baby
grogu and I love what you said where
thron just sees the mandalorians as a
threat certainly with this show and
especially with this episode with the
tease of the armorer going you must
unite the clans of Mandalore and we must
retake Mandalore it feels like this TV
era of Star Wars is is building up
towards
a big Mandalorian Centric storyline a
rise to power a a rise back to their
Glory but you have to wonder about well
what the heck happened to them before
the force awakens and I know that the
force awakens was made 10 years ago and
they didn't know that they're going to
make a TV show called The Mandalorian
but you know what I mean that thing of
like can you look at their absence from
the sequel Trilogy as an indication of
where their story might end up can we
look at that and go does thrawn and
Gideon do they ultimately uh succeed in
trying to squash down whatever's
happening on Mandalore and keeping them
separate and keeping them disparate that
may be the thing or fallonian company
might do what they did with the Clone
Wars where they're eventually leading up
to that movie era of films and then just
slowly and sneakily inserting scenes
behind the scenes inserting things in
between the scenes of the sequel Trilogy
that we've already seen you know what I
mean I could very easily see uh uh
um a TV show that flashes forward or a
TV show set during the force awakens The
Last Jedi and then the rise of Skywalker
that continues to follow dinjarin as he
gets older baby grogu as probably he
stays around the same age because if you
look like that during Order 66 he's
going to look like that during Force
awakens but just like telling us oh this
is where these characters are during
that
you know events of the Galaxy so there's
a lot that that this could all lead to
but I don't think that it's out of order
to think that thrawn would have some
kind of a hand in it because just from
now until Force awakens
in the same way that the original thrawn
appeared in that novel heir to the
Empire that took place after Return of
the Jedi and really won fans of the Star
Wars expanded universe Cannon over I
feel like this is thrawn's time like
they're gonna focus on him and I don't
think that they're gonna want to keep
the character around necessarily by the
time the first order in the force
awakens happens because by then it's
kylo Ren's Time It's the Return of
Palpatine's time but in terms of like
who the villainous threat is that's what
this TV era is going to focus on but
what it could mean for the mandalorians
I don't know maybe they're not
successful I don't know but I'm rooting
for them and the other thing I want to
say too folks and gentlemen I want to
get your take on this too Me growing up
being a fan of Star Wars but always
feeling like I was a bit of an outsider
I wasn't as well versed in the Canon as
someone like Tommy was I always felt
like
the three major factions of this world
were the Empire bad guys the Jedi good
guys and the Bounty Hunter slash
mandalorians kind of in the middle this
gray area this TV show feels like it's
moving that more and more towards the
side of good the mandalorians have a
code the mandalorians have a code now
Eric you brought up why would the new
Republic believe that a Mandalorian
would leave a piece of baskar have
anything to do with this Mafia getting
it why wouldn't they just kill moth
Gideon why would they take him you know
hostage or whatever I think that the
other focus of this show is that the
mandalorians don't have a good
reputation remember the entire years
that Darth Vader was active right there
being Palpatine's right-hand man who was
Darth Vader's right hand man Boba Fett
this guy wearing the Mandalorian Army
like this was a bounty hunter feared
throughout the Galaxy and maybe that
reputation has is still kind of sticking
around and characters like denjar and
have to kind of combat that and prove to
the Galaxy At Large hey we have a code
we're good we raise babies we help
innocent people this is who we are yeah
I just think that's a big leap to go
straight from fearing them as a
successful efficient bounty hunters to
walking into a messy messy uh
assassination job that also kills some
new Republic officers and being like Oh
yeah this is classic Mandalorian
Maneuvers Tommy you're about to say
something well no I just think like you
know to to the broader point in in uh in
war and in politics and in in in
Conflict Optics are everything and so
everyone's constantly framing their
opposition as the most evil bad thing in
the world and I'm not saying the EMP the
empire was certainly evil in Star Wars
but uh I think with mandalorians there's
so much Unknown about them in the same
way that there are there are you know
religions and and countries and Nations
that are very private in our world and
we don't know a lot about them so it's
so easy for people to manipulate and
create stories about them to make us
fear things to make people fear things
so you know I think that can certainly
translate onto the fictional pages of
star Wars I I am wondering what uh the
timeline we're dealing with here it
seems like felony and Favre are really
focused on the next 30 Years whereas I
kind of see like I don't want uh thrawn
to just be a linking point between the
the original trilogy and the sequel
Trilogy I want him to span beyond all
different eras I kind of like the idea
that he was like this Clone Wars figure
leading into the the Galactic Empire
period leading into now I mean when if
they're just trying to repeat the
Playbook that they had for Clone Wars
right where they're only setting stories
during a specific time period to add
context really the value of Clone Wars
and this might be a controversial
statement the value of Clone Wars wasn't
just like the the era of uh using Ahsoka
Tano to bridge those two eras it was the
fact that we introduced these characters
these themes these ideas the Clone
Troopers that could also show up in
later eras and Ahsoka Tano has shown up
after Return of the Jedi uh the fact
that we've had CAD Bane show up during
this area like I think that is like
what's really exciting so I don't want
like I want thrawn to like survive after
the events of episode
you know like I I want grogu to come
back during that era too yeah so I and I
yeah I know Ahsoka eventually everyone's
just gonna get too old that's true Eric
everyone does eventually die that is a
fact of this world and the Star Wars
Galaxy as far as I know actually Luke
tells us no one ever really dies oh good
point I didn't know I'm actually to you
Hector
um actually he says no one's ever really
gone touch me you're right
all right speaking of nerds we're gonna
talk about those nerds over at mint
mobile who are just changing the
wireless game is saving more and
spending less is one of your top goals
in 2023 why are you still paying insane
amounts of money every month for your
phone bill you sip switch into mint
mobile is the easiest way to save this
year as the first company to sell
premium wireless service online only
mint mobile lets you order from home and
save a ton with phone plans starting at
just 15 a month we have many many people
on the new rockstars team who have made
the switch to Mint mobile and uh it's an
easy switch they have the e-sim
technology they take the card out they
pop it into your new your existing phone
not new phone unless you want a new
phone maybe it's time to upgrade maybe
people are making fun of you you're
flipping your phone open get a new phone
then but if you like your old phone you
keep it mint mobile lets you keep it
folks for people looking for extra
savings this year mint mobile offers
premium Wireless for just 15 bucks a
month by going online only and
eliminating the traditional costs of
retail mint mobile passes significant
savings onto you and that's a pass I'll
always catch old soft hands bechtold
lining up a tight end running down the
field grabbing those savings from mint
mobile all plans come with unlimited
talking text plus high-speed data
delivered on the nation's largest 5G
Network use your own phone with any mint
Mobile plan it's switch easily in
minutes with these Sim as I said before
switch to bitmobile and get premium
wireless service starting at just 15
bucks a month to get your Wireless plan
for just 15 bills a month 15 bucks 15
shells 15 clams 15
get the plan shipped to your door for
free go to mintmobile.com break room
that's mintmobile.com break room and cut
your wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
admit mobile.com slash break room okay
I've got another question for you boys
my Star Wars boys my starboys why did
the armorer make Bo take the helmet off
and uh do we think this is gonna be the
end of Bo in the series or in the season
she's gonna go away she's gonna go get
her friends back I hope not I mean I
thought the obvious answer was you don't
keep a face as lovely as Katie sackhouse
under that helmet that's what I thought
it was I thought the armor was real
smart and I would love to see the rest
of those lovely actors they're good
looking people Emily swallow take
Fletcher take those helmets do you think
all of them I really thought we're gonna
see Emily swallow it's very excited I do
I know I was like oh I wonder what the
Armor's hair looks like I was so excited
gentlemen I have to believe that we're
gonna see Boca tan again this season and
moving forward
um you know Eric you really got me on
this kick of like what are we gonna see
in the Star Wars Galaxy post the rise of
Skywalker and I've been hearing chatter
online that that Star Wars is going to
shift and focus on mandalorians that
they are going to play a much bigger
role that grogu himself is going to
become like the protagonist of Star Wars
moving forward after Luke Skywalker
after Rey that it's going to be
something like Roku I would love to see
Bo Katan you know continue to age into
some lovely years but um I I hope that
she's still in the show and I think that
we're gonna see her bring back other
Mandalorian Clans and I've been saying
since the beginning of the Season that
Bo Katan is going to be that link and is
going to be the beginning of changing
this specific Children of the watch
covert into doing away with some of the
real strict regulations about having to
live life with a helmet on they're not
the Jedi and I feel like Star Wars since
the original movies up to now has kind
of learned the lesson of we're not going
to depict the Jedi as perfect they're
obviously flawed they're heroic
individuals but that kind of entire
organization is part of the reason why
things went bad during the the early
years of the Republic
um Tommy what do you think my man I'm
with you I think uh I think Boca tan is
the key to all of this to quote to
paraphrase a famous George Lucas quote
about Jar Jar Binks uh I think Boca tan
is what's going to be the uh the
connective tissue between these series
is and then they can't they I think they
have a great actress so yeah lots more
Bo I don't think this is the end of Bo
Katan at all I asked the question it was
a trap you didn't fall for it and I
applaud you now Hector
Eric after either one of you can take
this one this is just my final little
fun question I have what the [__] is Zeb
doing here ah no I'm not a huge Zeb
expert so I'm gonna need someone who's a
little more of a Zeb Aficionado to tell
me about this Hector what do you think
well what's great is that uh like any
good Star Wars uh product piece of media
TV show movie it's just gonna make you
want to dive into the rest of Star Wars
whether you've already seen it or not
I've already seen people online going I
want to re-watch Rebels this stuff
that's happening in the Mandalorian is
making me want to re-watch Rebels and uh
I think that this is just great smart
seed planting for what is going to
become the Ahsoka show and for great
characters Zeb being one of them a
fantastic character love that they
brought the voice actor back to depict
this character
um but uh yeah I mean Eric Eric you kind
of you get me on this train now of like
what other great
characters from the Star Wars Universe
the Galaxy that we've seen not just in
like the main Nine Movies could we
continue to see in the future of this
franchise and I think Dave filonian team
favro and Kathleen Kennedy and everybody
that's been producing these shows since
2019 have been really smart to mine the
amazing animated show characters
um I'm a huge fan of the Star Wars
comics and novels as well I think
there's a bunch of characters there that
can be pulled I'm a big fan of the high
Republic I'm getting back into reading
that stuff and trying to catch up and
it's so good and it's so fun and I know
that that's 200 years before whatever
but I'm reading High Republic stuff and
I'm seeing Maz Kanata along with Yoda
like Maz Kanata is a great character
that we can see in any era of the Star
Wars storyline including right now
during the New Republic which I think
would be really really cool
um so yeah I'm just excited about the
prospect of like not just focusing on
the movie characters it's the thing that
Star Wars fans have been asking for a
very long time expand the universe
there's more than 18 characters it's not
as small as we have come to know but I
guess it is kind of small because out of
all the people to bump into in a bar
we're gonna that's one of the characters
from Star Wars Rebels baby yeah and you
know what if it's kind of like a nice
sign because we know obviously Ahsoka is
alive uh if zeb's alive the rest of the
crew of the ghost is live if it would be
one thing if Zeb was in the corner
brooding over a drink just with a
haunted thousand yard stare in his
office like like what happened
our buddies in good spirits he's doing
all right so the rest of the uh the crew
of the ghost is probably doing fine too
I'm pretty sure if we don't see thrawn
and Hera next episode we're gonna see
Chopper rolling around curb stomping
someone in the background because he's a
little piece of [__] Chopper's not a
good guy I'm sorry I don't care what you
say I don't like Chopper they had
Choppers a little he's kind of adorable
but he also is like a murderer and we
should never let him go from that uh but
you know I'm sure the new Republic will
just Loop them into the amnesty program
and give him a nice desk job let him
work for Tim Meadows I think unless I'm
mistaken haven't we already technically
seen Chopper in the background in live
action in Roblox right right but yeah
somewhere in there I need to go back and
find that uh shot but I love that we've
already seen one of these characters
from rebels in live action cannot wait
to see the rest it's very exciting yeah
but Chopper not a great guy but I love
Chopper
we'll leave it there for this episode of
WikiLeaks and again the Easter egg
breakdown is coming tomorrow thank you
for your patience there you can follow
me at eavos follow Tommy Tommy back to
Apollo Hector and Hector is funny we'll
be back next week to react to episode
six I think it's gonna be a big one and
uh the break room check it out uh for
the rest of this week live every day at
3 P.M uh the Deep dive also has some fun
stuff coming up subscribe at Deep dive
INR uh we just recently did our Batman
one our Interstellar Deep dive is coming
out on April 7th and I got something
special planned for this Friday that
you're gonna love follow new rock stars
on all social media subscribe to
WikiLeaks wherever you get your podcast
thank you for watching and this this is
the way the way
[Laughter]
thank you